Jenny the headline was congressional
report says NFL waged improper campaign
to influence government study what would
be your headline for what went on
between the NFL and the NIH well that's
a good question i think it's what's a
complicated issue because the
intersection of football and science is
sort of a messy one right because you
have a football league that's you know
invested in proving that is committed to
health and safety for its business
concern so it wants to donate money to
help safety reasons so that it doesn't
lose you know people who want to send
their kids to play football and then on
the other side of it you have scientists
who faced similar pressures as any other
people in any other field and they want
funding for their research and so i
think the result is a little bit more
complicated perhaps and than it might
seem I mean I do think the NFL messed up
in a big way by calling their grant to
the NIH unrestricted when they gave 30
million dollars in funds they said it
was unrestricted but they obviously had
a plan in mind for certain kinds of
studies they wanted to fund with it I
think they would have been better served
not calling it unrestricted not sort of
boxing themselves into that and if you
know whatever their motivations were for
spraying money around or doing certain
kinds of studies if they had not labeled
it unrestricted I don't think they would
have been attacked so harshly in the
Congressional report so Jenny explained
to me in the listeners why exactly were
they trying to pull the money away from
Robert stern who's at Boston University
part of the concussion legacy Institute
and really you know really has been at
the forefront of this whole thing he
seems like the guy you should be giving
your money to right and and i think that
there's a lot of search in this field
that deserves to be funded right so i
think that that is where they look bad
the NIH peer review panel came up with
Robert stern as study that they wanted
to fund
the NFL had says they had a slightly
different study in mind a longitudinal
study that instead of focusing on CTE
and perhaps a way to diagnose CTE in a
living they wanted to do a longitudinal
study that would also add value that was
follow different groups of people at
different ages who have played contact
sports or not played contact sports to
basically answer the question of if my
eight-year-old son gets concussion
playing soccer or the possible long-term
consequences I think both research
studies are valid and this is where we
get back to the debate of where the
money goes I think the back and forth
we've been hearing the past few days is
a couple different research groups who
want to use the money to advance their
studies and there isn't enough money
going around and I think that that's
sort of the root of the controversy here
I guess what I don't understand jenny is
if you're the NFL and there's been the
PBS report there's been the movie
concussion all these different things I
don't you don't you think before you
actually make any moves in this regard
you mean like don't you think wait a
minute maybe that's what we want but if
this gets misconstrued the wrong way
we're going to take another massive PR
head here absolutely because you know
public trust in the NFL is so thin right
now when it comes to health and safety
and more importantly player trust and I
think you saw a lot of players yesterday
reacting to the report on Twitter and it
just sort of underscores the feelings
that the NFL has been trying to outrun I
mean but their past of you know in
action and you know kind of ignoring the
head trauma issued they've been trying
to run that for so long which is why
this report was damning because it was
saying the problems are not just in the
past they're also in the present so I
think the lack of all awareness there of
how whatever their motivations were I
mean I do think there are legitimate
reasons why you wouldn't want one group
to get eighty percent of their theramin
million dollar grant not specifically
because of that group itself just it's
in science it's good to spread around
money different research groups however
since that group is led by someone who
has been critical of the league in the
past it's
sort of um you know they're the sort of
blind the nfl's being blind in this case
I think and didn't show a lot of
foresight in understanding you know if
we push back against this how it would
look especially when they had agreed on
on a similar study to the one that the
BU group has proposed Jenny I saw the
NFL just released a press release for
instant replay changes I think this
literally happened since you've been on
the phone with us are you aware of this
you know what the changes are or did
this catch it did we catch you while
you're on the phone while they just
released it you know they they just have
just brought it to my doubts right
before I jumped up to get on the phone
but I i think it's just sort of i don't
think there's any huge changes i think
that it's just clarifying the process of
what is reviewable and what is not i
think it's more specifically outlining
it if i understand it yeah looks to me
like instead of telling you what will or
won't be reviewable anymore now they're
just going to say here's the only things
that aren't reviewable appreciate the
time Jenny yeah thanks for having me on
the Dan Patrick show weekday mornings on
audience